one of the big problems people face
today regarding religion or regarding
the notion of god is a problem that i
would call something like the reality of
god versus the reality of the world and
it might seem like an abstract problem
which matters only to theologians but it
actually ends up manifesting itself in
everybody's life actually whether you
are religious or not and it ends up
manifesting itself in opposites so it
manifests itself in things like for
example in scripture
you have christ who says something like
call no one on earth father because
god in heaven is your father you know or
christ saying things like no one is good
but god
and you'll find many places in scripture
where christ seems to bring everything
to god and to reduce the world to almost
nothing
and then there are other places in
scripture for example where we have the
law of god where we have the
prescription of god where we have christ
saying do this in remembrance of me
where on the other hand he seems to be
saying that these things are really
important and so how do we bring this
together how do we make sense of this
and how does it
help us understand some of the discourse
that people are using and how we often
feel trapped in opposites sometimes and
struggle to uh to find a way out so
we're gonna look at some of this and see
how it relates to your everyday life
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so this question is very important today
especially in the kind of cultural
battle you know in the the cultural war
we can call them
let me give you a few examples once
again
and uh and you'll see what i'm talking
about so for example a famous
verse that is being used very often
today is the verse where it says there's
neither jew nor greek slave nor free
male nor female for you're all one in
christ jesus and so many people will use
that verse to argue for things like you
know the abolition of gender roles you
know for having women priests or also
for other even more kind of notions of
fluid identity and uh and you know
certain woke values let's say will be
we'll be hiding people will use this
verse to argue for those types of
positions
so what's interesting is that
if you look at that from that side
you'll notice
that this is something which is
absolutely there in scripture christ
does it all the time like i mentioned
before christ says
none is good but god you know christ
says don't call anyone on earth your
father
there are so many places where christ
seems to say that you know even places
for example when he says that talks
about the person who sells the field in
order to get the pearl or to rip your
eye out you know if it causes you to
fall all of this type of thinking you
know moves towards the idea that the
world itself is dangerous the world is
dangerous in the sense that it can
become idolatry and this is of course
something which we find in certain
strains of christianity today where all
forms are seen as suspicious we want to
remove liturgy we want to remove a
ritual because we feel like ritual is
suspicious it can be idolatrous we can
be attached to it and it can actually
turn us away from god
and there is actually position for that
in scripture i mentioned some verses but
there are many other verses which will
go in that direction now this is of
course the problem the problem
of so many types of interpretation is
when we take one
verb we take a line and we draw it
through scripture and we find all the
verses that kind of agree with the
position and we just argue from that now
what's fascinating for example is that
for every verse that i've mentioned
in scripture there is a counter example
and so for example it says there you
know there's neither a june or greek
slave nor free male nor female for you
all one in christ jesus and then christ
will then in other places say that and
even saint paul will talk about you know
the gospel going out to the jew first
and then to the the pagan or then to the
gentile there are other places where for
example saint paul talks about gender
roles and talks about the role of the
man the role of the father the role of
the wife the role of the woman in church
and you think well how does this jive so
what happens is people will tend to
create a false hierarchy they'll try to
say well this this verse here the one
where it says there's neither there are
no divisions there's no separation
there's no particularity we're all one
that is really that's the real truth and
the other one that's just kind of detail
it's not really important uh but you
when if you follow the line you'll see
that this happens all the time for
example when it says when christ says
self says
you know none is good but god
you have to realize that there is an
apporia in what he's saying because in
the very creation of the world god
creates the world and you know
at almost every day of creation he says
and he saw that it was good
and so what is going on here how is it
that we can have saying this you know in
one place and the other the other
example that i gave which is uh do not
call anyone on earth your father there's
another place in scripture where saint
paul
says to the corinthians that he became
their spiritual father that he is their
father in christ so one again once again
what is going on here now
what's going on here is something about
the very nature of reality and the very
nature of god which is that
in in the modern world the modern world
has taken up this kind of dialectical
thinking this kind of oppositional
thinking and we we tend to frame it in a
certain way so for example we talk about
nominalism and univocalism now these are
fancy terms but what it means is that in
the late middle ages there are some
thinkers we talk about you know uh
about occam or don scotus akam is
associated with nominalism and scotus is
associated with univocalism now people
argue for example that it's not totally
there and they're thinking that it's
later people that interpreted it and
made it more radical it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter for our purpose our
purpose is that this is how the world
started to frame itself as these kind of
two opposites one was one was that god
is so high above reality
that nothing you can say
can touch god like you know that god is
beyond everything and that that reality
nothing in reality
is connected to god so when you say that
god is good we don't mean it in the same
way that we say other things are good
when we say that god is love we don't
mean it in the same way that we mean
talk about the secular love there's a
there's a radical disjunct between god
and
all the rest of reality now this is what
we call nominalism on the other hand
there's something we call univocalism
which is that no that
everything that god because god is is
the source of reality then
god is
necessarily has to be related to the
things we say so when we say you know we
talk about love in the world it has to
be the same as the love that god has
because or else what would it even mean
to talk about love in the world and so
god is love but supreme love like the
being of supreme supreme love so we have
the same type of love that we have it's
just it's just more than we have and
bigger and so god is in that sense god
is like the super everything so
everything that you think about god is
the super everything and so what so what
the the nominalist will say of the
univocalist is that you're trapping god
in creation
you're making god part of creation and
that is a mistake you're making him into
kind of a pagan god god is beyond
creation he's the source of creation and
so what the univocalist will accuse the
the
the nominalist of is saying you're
putting god so high above the world that
he's completely disjunct and you're
making the world arbitrary you're making
all of reality arbitrary because there's
no connection between the source of
reality and reality itself and so
everything here is just arbitrary
because we there's no connection to or
at least god's will is arbitrary god
acts arbitrarily in the world like some
divine tyrant that just kind of acts
without no without without without no
connection to how the world lays itself
out now this like i said this might seem
like uh like a arbit like something
which isn't that important but it ends
up playing itself
playing its out very importantly in the
world and it
looks like for example the the it can
look like something like a kind of bare
evangelical service where everything is
we attempt to strip everything down
because we find the world to be
suspicious now that is would be the
extreme of kind of uh you could say
of a nominalism and then you have the
other side like an extreme univocalism
which is to think that every little
detail of for example the liturgy is
supremely important and we have to we
have to practice it exactly the way it's
written and we have to do things exactly
the way it is because all of these
things all of these things in the world
are actually manifesting
god they are
a little body of god you could say and
so how do we deal with it
it's really important to deal with this
because it will lead to several
conclusions that you see
in the world today
and arguments that people will use
you'll find people who
who for example refuse to participate in
religion because they'll say things like
multiplicity is an illusion you know
it's all maya it's all an illusion you
know all forms are relative and
therefore
you know i'm a universalist which means
that i just see the transcendent
absolute but i don't want to get dirtied
up in uh in these particular forms but
the same type of argument can lead to
another
excess you know which is
that uh you hate all forms and so the
the universalist loves all forms and
because he kind of loves all forms and
sees them only at these kind of relative
illusory uh representations of god he's
like eh you know i'm not going to do all
any of this
and then the other one hate all forms
and see them all as idols and thinks all
creation is suspect this also leads to
the kind of conspiracy theory symbolism
which is that as soon as you see meaning
in the world because you don't believe
the world is actually kind of full of
the manifestation of god then you
immediately see ill will and all ritual
is satanic you know and you see that and
the saddest part is really to see even
catholics and orthodox christians embark
in this like as soon as they see a
ritual that isn't their own liturgy they
immediately think it's satanic it's like
just because something is ritualized
doesn't mean it's satanic just because
it is anyway so there are different
versions of that of course it leads also
like i said it leads to like the the new
age mush as well to this kind of it's
like it's the opposite but you can see
how it all leads to the same type of
thinking uh which is that you know i can
just pick and choose all the forms that
i want you know and all these forms are
good so i can just kind of navigate
through any of them it doesn't matter
none of this matters right it's all it's
all it's all maya anyways where it's all
kind of bodies of god and and and there
isn't any form of of balance you know
and it's very difficult to buy to find
balance now
the balance has to be found in the
aporia when i use the word of pory i
know maybe some people might not know
what it means it means like a
contradiction which points a
contradiction which is held and which
points to something which is beyond
reason which is beyond uh something that
you can totally capture in words and so
the tr the absolute transcendence of god
and the absolute imminence of god are
actually related to each other but you
can't you can't formulate them at the
same time
it's very difficult you can't find an
image in which you formulate both the
absolute transcendence of god and the
absolute imminence of god at the same
time so what you'll see in scripture is
you'll see moves you'll see moves
towards absolute transcendence we could
call them ascetic moves where the the
the desires to kind of clear out all the
forms to show that they're that they're
not enough that they're not sufficient
that god is always above them so these
are the places where christ says things
like none is good but god you know where
where uh saint paul will say all these
multiplicities they're not real what's
real is our unity in christ and so
you'll find moves like that and then
you'll find other moves in scripture
where the opposite is happening where
christ or saint paul or in general just
the law or the the temple or the rituals
which are given are given as things you
need to participate in things that are
real things that that have are actually
manifesting god that they are
remembrance of god in in a real way not
in just some kind of uh secondary
illusory way but that that they they
participate in the life of god and so
when christ gives baptism and and
communion as a ritual you know when
saint paul talks about the different
roles for different genders when saint
paul kind of tells people how to act
these are
relative goods but they are goods that
we need to embark in they are not
relative in the sense that they can just
be discounted and ignored they are the
manner in which kind of god fills up the
world but they can be dangerous because
if we think that they're absolute then
we're missing the point the point is
obviously that they're pointing towards
god but it's the same thing if we only
kind of focus on this the absolute of
god's transcendence then we miss
something important as well which is
that because he is transcendent he
actually fills all of reality with his
being and so
what i'm going to do for you is i
usually don't read text directly from
the church fathers but i want to read
from you a text from
from saint dianis the areopagite i've
mentioned him several times on this
channel he is one of the most important
saints in terms of mysticism
and in terms of understanding this
symbolic world and how it is that this
symbolic world
is both the reality of how god manifests
himself in all of creation
but how all of creation has and must
point towards god who is also completely
above and completely transcendent and
completely infinite above all all things
and so you'll see if you watch my videos
you'll see that i sometimes make these
two moves and like i said you can't make
them at the same time but sometimes
they'll say things like god is beyond
being god is beyond all name god is
beyond all definition
then you'll find me in another place
arguing for how this manifests christ
and how these all these different little
elements of reality are manifesting god
in reality so let me read a little text
from you from saint dionysis
from the divine names and
i'll read it and maybe i'll make a few
comments i'll skip some parts as well
you can find it yourself you know just
by google searching some of the words
i'm using
um
so sandianes it says uh with regard to
the super essential being of god
transcendent goodness transcendently
there
no lover of the truth which is above all
truth will seek to praise it as word or
power or mind or life or being
no it is at a total remove from every
condition movement life imagination
conjecture name discourse thought
conception being rest dwelling unity
limit infinity the totality of existence
and so he yeah saint daniel says loves
to string those words together but what
he's doing is he's saying it's like if
you if you love if you understand
the super essential identity being of
god that is that god is beyond being
actually beyond all all thought all
every all of the things that he
mentioned right you will never think
that you can praise him as one of these
things
and then you think oh here we are like
here it is in this kind of transcendent
moment where he's saying god is beyond
all things and so we can't recognize
them in anything that exists right um
but then saint diana just continues and
now he goes to this to the other move
now right after what i just read when he
says that he is beyond everything beyond
the totality of existence and yet
since it is the underpinning of goodness
and by merely being there is the cause
of everything
to praise this divinely beneficial
providence you must turn to all of
creation
it is there at the center of everything
and everything has it for a destiny when
we talk about theosis i've mentioned
this a few times before i mentioned this
with jedi for example when we were i was
talking to him
it's not just humans that are meant to
be deified it's everything that is meant
to be deified everything has as its
destiny god okay
so it is there before all things and in
all things
hold
it is before all things and in it all
things hold together this description
citing colossians because it is there
the world has come to be and exists
all things long for it the intelligent
and rational long forward by way of
knowledge
the lower strata by way of perception
the remainder by way of the stirrings of
being
the stirrings of being alive and in
whatever fashion befits their condition
so what it's saying is that all things
that exist long to move into this
transcendence and they do it
by the means that they have at whatever
level of being they exist because they
are connected to this transcendent god
fills the world with himself
but the world is not himself but it's
called to kind of move into god and so
all things at their level can
participate in the life of god by
whatever it is that they have and so
like you said the higher beings because
we're intelligence this is how we are
the image of god that's not the only way
right the the
the idea of even perceiving
is something which is in the image of
god and then just the stirrings of being
alive right this just this even the
desires even these passions even these
raw uh passions are
are ways in which we can participate in
the life of god
and so realizing this the theologians
praise it by every name
and as the nameless one
for they call it nameless when they
speak of so i'm not gonna go into this
but he talks about how god is nameless
and he talks about how when god you know
doesn't really want to reveal his name
to moses and basically says i am the one
who is uh uh he's he's in a way rebuking
moses by ask by
that moses is asking him for a proper
name and he's saying i don't have a
proper name right my name is beyond all
names but then he says at the same time
then then we also praise him with all
these other names that god has and then
he just lists them you know being life
light the truth uh he talks about the
beautiful the wise the beloved the god
of god lord of lords holy of holies you
know the cause of ages and just goes on
and on and on just all these these terms
for god righteousness sanctification um
et cetera et cetera you can go through
it uh yourself uh all the lists of the
names of god and all the images that are
used to talk about god
so here he comes to his
his kind of conclusion you could say
and so it is the cause of all
and as transcending all
he is rightly nameless
and yet has the names of everything that
is
truly he has dominion over all and all
things revolve around him for he is
their cause their source and their
destiny he is all in all as scripture
affirms and certainly he is to be
praised as being for all things the
creator and originator the one who
brings them the power which returns them
to itself and all this in the one single
irrepressible and supreme act so what he
means is that this is eternally true
that the supreme eternal act you could
say
makes all of this true in simultaneity
that is both this this kind of this this
moving out of god into creation and the
bringing back of god into himself you
know this is very mysterious but it can
help you understand a lot of things
about
about you know how
things that happen in scripture even the
incarnation the the crucifixion the
resurrection are eternally true in god
they are eternal realities in god
like i said it's mysterious but it's
important if you don't have that at some
point you're going to run into some
serious problems in terms of your
theology now once again for many people
this might seem
still a little bit abstract and i thank
you for following me all the way here if
you've had the courage to do so but this
true truth that we just talked about is
true at every level of reality it is
fractally true it is true of any object
you can perceive and so
you know let's you you what example are
we going to use let's use a chair
because it's
an example that i like to use and so
the being of the chair right the the the
fact that it's a chair the chairness of
the chair
is beyond all the parts of the chair it
has to be
and so it it it's beyond all the parts
of the chair
but it is the source of all the parts of
the chair as well that is it is the
reason
why these parts are even perceived as
parts of the chair
you know
themselves and they're not seen as
something else like a bit of wood or a
bit of paint or you know a branch or
whatever that the fact that we see them
as legs as different aspects of the
chair
is because they're held together by the
identity of the chair which is
above the chair itself and so you can't
if you say that the leg of the chair is
the chair you're lying if you say the
back of the chair is the chair you're
lying there it's not none of the
elements of the chair are the chair and
so to try to name them
by their elements is to
is to miss the major the basic point
that the identity of the chair
is beyond it but at the same time
because the identity of the chair
gives reason for these parts of the
chair to be parts of the chair therefore
it fills the chair with its presence
and it makes those parts
let's say
little names for the chair so it is a
leg of a chair it is the back of a chair
it is it is you know the the aspects of
the chair and so they become like we
have to look to all the parts of the
chair and at the same time see that
the chair itself is beyond all the parts
to be able to get the full movement of
reality right the movement up and the
movement down this kind of you know
these two movements that i talk about
for example with john vervicky all the
time it's kind of eminent this this
emanation and this emergent reality this
is what saint dionysus is talking about
and he is he is actually giving us a
very powerful
solution to many of the problems where
whether it is complex systems or just
the way in which the church exists or
just in how we can interpret scripture
without
falling into these absolutes the balance
is difficult to find it's very difficult
to find the balance between
recognizing how all forms are relative
to the highest purpose but also how
they're real and without them you can't
sit on the chair without the legs of the
chair even though the the identity of
the chair transcends its elements and so
i hope this is a little useful to kind
of understand you know the problems you
run into i'm sure if you think about it
you will remember many times where you
you've been kind of trapped in this
moment where someone has presented to
you or even in your own mind presented
to you an argument which wants to make
god transcendent or reality transcended
and wants to negate all the particulars
and then on the other side as well where
there's kind of this obsession with with
the particulars and an incapacity to see
how the unity of something transcends
its multiplicity and so like i said
thank you for your attention as usual
and uh and more videos coming very soon
i'll talk to you very soon bye-bye
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your
usual podcast platform but we also have
a website with a blog and several very
interesting articles by very intelligent
people that have been thinking about
symbolism on all kinds of subjects we
also have a clips channel a facebook
group you know there's a whole lot of
ways that you can get more involved in
the exploration and the discussion of
symbolism don't forget that my brother
matsuya wrote a book called the language
of creation which is a very powerful
synthesis of a lot of the ideas that
explore and so please
go ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support